been defunding a six billion dollar nypd
budget not enough resources are being
put into the very kinds of social
programming and investments that prevent
uh crime the militarization of our
police is enabled by the federal
government
welcome back to funding the police
coming with some serious consequences in
aoc's congressional district major
felonies are up by 57 compared to just
two years ago
judge
i thought crime should pay it seems like
liberal prosecutors today are making
crime
doesn't pay at all
well actually i think that what the
prosecutors today are doing especially
the progressive lexus who were supported
by uh george soros are making actually
crime pay for the criminal uh they know
right now that they could go into stores
and they can steal up to a thousand
dollars in many states and keep whatever
they get and then that with the no bail
laws they can keep doing it again and
again and again there is no incentive
for them to stop i think the saddest
part of all this is that we take someone
like andrea ocasio-cortez and we say she
should be the voice of reason in this
issue of law enforcement and crime she
knows nothing of crime she knows nothing
of law enforcement this is a woman who
has no background in this and for some
reason she got all the attention and now
what we've got is a woman complaining
when we've got a 57 in percent increase
in major crime in new york city cops are
leaving the nypd in in in groves because
in droves because what they don't want
they don't even want to wait for their
pensions to vest they just want to get
out and police are demoralized they're
they're they're dehumanized and they're
barely able to defend themselves let
alone make an arrest so what we have in
this country now is the continued fight
to defund the police by the democrats
but with more and more people becoming
victims there's going to be a movement
very soon where people are going to be
fed up they're going to say have had
enough ron desantis the governor in
florida good for him he removed a
soros-funded prosecutor this guy doesn't
know what it means to be a prosecutor
you prosecute crime you protect the
victim you make society safe and you
deter other criminals these people know
nothing of it and we're paying the price
not only are major felonies up but
homicides up 44 in the last couple of
years the defund the police movement has
decimated communities in many of those
communities are communities of color
harold do you think the democrats are
going to pay your price for that this
november
if we don't get our ways right we we
could i think uh i'm a huge voice we
there's not a slightly different opinion
on this issue we're aligned
police officers need to be funded
reform of our bail laws need to happen
again
the instinct to perform those laws
judged you know was to try to ensure
that non-violent criminals might not
find themselves spending more time in
jail than they would before if they were
convicted of the crime what's happening
here is the exact opposite i read
senator you probably may have seen in
our local newspaper uh the new york post
one of our papers our ex our former one
of our former top police officials
counterterrorism official guy named john
miller
said that these bell reform laws judge
have set new york city back a decade in
terms of law and order uh that needs to
change and i'm a believer as many are
around this table your city makes it two
guys including one of your left they're
in greg who's believe i love saying greg
sitting to to my left uh that greg is
one of the great advocates for what we
need to do to address this mental health
issue on streets not only in new york
where you kind of think a preponderance
of our challenges in big cities along
the northeast corridor
we've got to we've got to do better
democrat republican alike and to deal
with the politics democrats if we don't
get right on this issue
there's no amount of building back
better
that's going to that's going to make it
right no doubt jesse it seems to me the
media simply gives the democrats and the
bite administration a complete pass if
it was president trump just crossing the
street the wrong way he might get a
ticket for that but literally the
democrats seem to get
a complete pass from most of the media
on a crime are you saying
that the media is biased you know i have
i have come to decades yeah i think we
all know years ago
on aoc you got to cut her a little bit
of slack though just because you know
she's planning a wedding
those invitations aren't going to pick
themselves senator um
she has not spoken to the mayor of new
york city in over a year
why not they're both democrats they both
have juice let's work together for the
good of the city but she's petty so she
won't do that
she doesn't work across the aisle she
doesn't work on her own side of the
aisle right now she can't even bring
home the bacon you know she hasn't had a
single electric car charging station
installed in her district not a single
one and that's her main issue now the
main issue for people in new york is
crime and she talks more about crime in
israel than she talks about crime here
in new york city i went back and looked
at her website for press releases she
hasn't put out a release in a year about
crime in new york the one thing she did
say about crime she had to empty the
prisons that's the only thing she said
about crime now
if if you look at what she said when
mayor adams came out and said he wants
to hire more police she says this
violence i don't mean people committing
it i also mean the system and the power
committing it against the people so it's
like a recession she's just redefining
crime and violence so if you're a
convicted felon or if you're a
you know someone out there not convicted
yet or you're unemployed you are a
victim of violence by the racist and
capitalist system in this country that's
how she sees things so she's seeing
figuratively american capitalism is
stabbing you in the gut the american
criminal justice system is figuratively
shooting you in the head and robbing you
so everybody out there
is a victim of the american system
that's how she sees it so that's how she
redefines it greg it seems to me that
when you when you think about where we
are on the issue from defunding the
police you see the prosecutors not
prosecuting
so many of the big cities especially
once in california your home state you
seem to have lost their minds from my
perspective
what do we do besides win elections that
would make a huge difference well i'm
definitely going to bring it up to her
at the wedding
you got an invite yeah i got an invite
i'll be there you know the thing is you
know what's great about aoc is that
she's so wrong
on everything but it forces everybody to
do their homework right it's like she
comes out she says something wrong and
then we all have to do the research
right because she won't do it she will
say crime is not happening and then we
go wait a second so the statistic the 57
percent uh has gone up
since she's been in power
that's a correlation and i would say a
causation but that came from a new york
post article written by a former
detective paul morrow these this is the
research the crime stats that we end up
having to do and having to research
there's a ton of stats in that article
that just make her look so bad uh there
her constituents she's been elected are
more likely to be mugged assaulted shot
at and yet she's the one who claimed she
almost died right on january 6th right
remember that she was so close to the
action i'm sorry she wasn't close to the
action and in in in the bronx she's in
her tesla with her frenchie and her
dorky fiance if she's bronx so was
coldplay now you're definitely not
invited yes
coming up the teachers union's president
is blaming conservatives for the growing
crisis in america's classrooms
hi everyone i'm brian kilmeade i want
you to do me a favor i want you to click
to subscribe to the fox news youtube
page this is the only way that i know
for sure that you're not going to miss
any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on fox you can get it all here on
youtube so subscribe right now